el gráfico debajo muestra la cantidad de
jugo de naranja que blancanieves le dio
a cada uno de los siete enanos si
blancanieves redistribuyera el jugo de
naranja de manera que a cada enano le
tocara la misma cantidad de jugo cuanto
jugo le tocaría a cada enano todas las
mediciones están redondeadas a un cuarto
de onza líquida más cercana veamos
cuánto le ha tocado a cadena no tenemos
aquí esta gráfica y estas son onzas
líquidas aquí son diez onzas líquidas 11
12 13 onzas líquidas y cada una está
dividida en 1 2 3 4 en cuartas partes
así que para estos enanos de aquí
tenemos que hay 10 onzas líquidas más 12
cuartos
aquí son dos cuartos además de estas
diez onzas líquidas que le tocan cada
uno de estos enanos entonces veamos aquí
en este punto tenemos 10 onzas líquidas
más dos cuartos pero dos cuartos y lo
simplificamos es igual a un medio
dividimos 2 entre 2 y 4 entre 2 nos va a
dar uno y aquí abajo nos va a dar 2 así
que son 10 enteros un medio
y esto es lo que le corresponde a cada
uno de los enanos pero cuántos enanos
hay aquí hay 1 2 3 4 5 enanos así que
esto va a estar multiplicado por cinco
como podemos hacer esta multiplicación
una forma de hacerlo es dejando todo
esto en términos de medios y para
hacerlo tenemos que estos 10 enteros hay
que transformarlos a mitades a medios
cuántos son 10 enteros en medios pues
multiplicamos por 2 y lo dividimos entre
2 2 por 10 va a ser 20 y lo dividimos
entre 2 lo dejamos en medios
si yo divido 20 entre 2 me va a dar 10
es la misma cantidad y a esto le agrego
éste un medio
este es un medio que tengo aquí y ahora
tendré aquí 20 medios más un medio va a
ser igual a 21 medios y es lo que tengo
aquí y ahora a esto lo voy a multiplicar
por 5 que es cada uno de estos enanos de
acá
esto nos va a dar que es 21 por 5
esto es 105 medios muy bien ya tenemos
todo lo que hay de jugo de naranja
repartido entre todos estos enanos ahora
nos falta ver a estos enanos de acá a
estos enanos de aquí les tocó más jugo
de naranja ya que vemos que les tocaron
11 12 onzas más un cuarto éste es un
cuarto son 12 onzas líquidas más un
cuarto por un enano dos enanos
ahora tenemos estas 12 onzas y un cuarto
por 2
estos dos enanos y vamos a hacer lo
mismo que hicimos acá esto de aquí lo
quiero transformar en cuartos la forma
de hacerlo es dejar estos dos enteros en
cuartos multiplicó y divido por cuatro
si multiplico 12 por 4 me va a dar que
es 48 48 entre 4 si a 48 lo divido entre
4 me va a dar 12 así que estos 12 son
estos
y a estos cuarenta y ocho cuartos le
sumo este cuarto de acá más un cuarto y
ahora voy a tener 48 más 149 como todo
está en cuartos puedo sumarlo
directamente estos son 49 cuantos y
recordemos que las fracciones en las que
el numerador es más grande que el
denominador se les llama fracciones
impropias y ahora a esta fracción así
como está en cuartos la voy a
multiplicar por el número de enanos que
recibieron esta cantidad de jugo estos 2
y 49 cuartos por 2 va a ser igual a 49
por 29 por 2 18 escribo que las unidades
tengo una decena que la llevo 4 por 288
decenas más una decena que ya llevaba
son 98 98 cuartos puedo simplificar esto
para dejarlo en medios de manera que lo
pueda sumar con esta cantidad si yo
/ 98 entre 2 y 4 entre 2 voy a tener
todo simplificado en medios 98 entre 2
va a ser igual a 49
esto es 49 y 4 entre 2 va a ser igual a
2 49 medios es lo mismo que 98 cuartos y
ahora sí como todo lo tengo en medios
los puedo sumar
105 medios más 49 medios esto lo
quitamos va a ser igual a cómo está todo
en medios puedo sumarlo directamente el
numerador con numerador 95 son 14 llevó
una son cuatro unidades llevo una decena
cuatro decenas más cero decenas más una
que llevábamos son cinco decenas i
tenemos una centena 154 medios esto lo
puedo dividir entre 2 154 entre 2 me va
a dar igual
77 entonces la cantidad total de onzas
líquidas que se le dieron a todos estos
enanos todas las onzas líquidas en total
fueron 77 onzas líquidas que se le
dieron a los enanos y si queremos que
cada enano reciba la misma cantidad
tenemos que dividir esto entre 7 va a
ser esta cantidad total de jugo entre 7
enanos y aquí 7 por una 777 de acero
bajo este otro 7 y el 7 por una 7 es
exacto 7 menos 7 es igual a 0 por lo que
a cadena no le debe de tocar 11 onzas
líquidas de jugo de naranja